ليلى هذه هي مسيره اخرى ضمن مسيرات
الاحتجاج ضد هذه الحرب التي يصفها
المتظاهرون هنا بانها حرب مجرمه وعبثه
وانها تحولت الى حرب باده ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني يمكن ان نقول ان هذا هو الاسبوع
العاشر وربما تجاوز ذلك او الحادي عشر
لهذه التظاهرات المتواصله باستثناء
الاسابيع الاولى التي منعت فيها هذه
التظاهرات الان هذا هو الاسبوع الحادي ع
الذي يخرج فيه متظاهرون للمطالبه بنفس
المطلب الذي يتكرر وقف اطلاق النار ومن ثم
ادخال المساعدات يقول المتظاهرون ان هناك
مجزره واباده تتم ضد سكان غزه على مراه
ومسمع من العالم يطالبون الحكومه الفرنسيه
باتخاذ موقف اكثر حزما واكثر جديه يقولون
انه لا يليق
بفرنسا ان يك له مثل هذا الموقف على الاقل
في البدايه في بدايه هذا الحرب والذي كان
موقفا وصف بانه مالئا ولذلك من بين
الشعارات التي نسمع الان نسمع هذا الشعار
ان اسرائيل قاتله
و الدول الاوروبيه هي متواطئه لكن يمكن ان
اقول ليلى ايضا ان هذه التظاهرات تزداد من
جهه زخما على مستوى الحجم وتزداد ايضا
زخما على مستوى انضمام فئات اخرى لها
كثيرين من الذين لم يكونوا قد انضموا
اليها في البدايه الان مع ثقل الصور التي
تصلهم من غزه وماسا يتها وتعنت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه انضمت فئات اخرى نشاهدها تحضر
هذه التظاهرات بشكل مستمر يمكن ان اقول
ايضا ليلى ان موقف الحكومه
الفرنسيه نفسه قد تغير بالمقارنه مع ما
شهدناه في البدايه الموقف الفرنسي الان
اصبح يدعو بشكل واض
الى وقف اطلاق النار وهناك اختيار
للخارجيه الفرنسيه لصيغه تقول الى هدنه
فوريه تؤدي الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
وهذا تغير كبير في الموقف الفرنسي ايضا
الموقف الفرنسي الان اعلن بشكل واضح انه
يرفض سياسه التهجير التي دعا اليها بعض
الوزراء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذا ناهيك
عن دعوه فرنسا او اعلانها انها ستفر
عقوبات على من وصفتهم بالمستوطنين
المتطرفين في الضفه الغربيه الذين يقومون
بهجمات ضد الفلسطينيين ودعوتها الى تمديد
هذه العقوبات على المستوى الاوروبي اذا
هناك تغير واضح في المستوى الفرنسي لماذا
هذا التغير من جهه يمكن ان نقول ان هناك
الصور الماساويه وحرب الاباده التي تقوم
بها اسرائيل لم تترك للفر نعم
نعم هنا
هذهه نعم الى اي درجه هذه الصور تصل عبر
وسائل الاعلام الرسميه ام ان جل يصل عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي يعني هذه نقطه
ايضا يهم ان نعرف اذا كان حصل فيها تغيير
ايضا فعلا ليلى يمكن ان نقول ان التحول
الذي شهدته فرنسا على مستوى قف التي نتحدث
عنها يهم ايضا وسائل الاعلام في بدايه هذه
الحرب كان هناك موقف من وسائل الاعلام
مساند بشكل شبه مطلق
للسياسه الاسرائيليه ولما يوصف بحق
اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها وطريقه
التعاطي وتاثير الخبر الاعلامي كان منحازا
بشكل واضح للروايه الاسرائيليه الروايه
الفلسطينيه لم تكن تجد طريقها الى معظم
وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه كان يتم التعا تل
مع الفلسطينيين كارقام حتى عندما يتم
الحديث عن تعرض المئات والالاف الى القتل
كان يتم الحديث عليهم كارقام لم يتم
التاكد منها وفق كثير من النشرات بينما
كان يتم تقديم الروايه الاسرائيليه في
صوره اناس واشخاص واسماء ووجوه تعاني
وبالتالي كان الواضح ان هناك انحياز واضح
ويمكن ان ان نقول انه مطلق للروايه
الاسرائيليه هناك الان تغيير واضح على
مستوى الخطاب الاعلامي وخاصه في الصحافه
المكتوبه وفي المؤسسات الاعلاميه التي
المعروفه على كل حال نتحدث عن صحيفه
لوموند مثلا او صحيفه ليبيراسيون التي
بدات تفرد عددا من صفحاتها وافتتاحيات
للحديث على ما يحدث في غزه وان ما يحدث
الان يتجاوز منطق الدفاع عن النفس الحديث
عن الماساه التي يعيشها سكان غزه وايضا
الحديث الحديث عن تعنت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الان هناك اسئله تطرح ايضا
لدى معظم وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه عن الهدف
من هذه الحرب وانها لم تؤدي من جهه الى
نتائجها التي ربما كانت اسرائيل تقول انها
تهدف اليها وفي نفس الوقت تؤدي الى مقتل
عشرات الالاف 22 الف قتيل في افتتاحيه
صحيفه ليبراسيون لبارحه صحيفه لمون وعدد
كبير من وسائل الا تؤكد ان هناك تغيرا
كبيرا او على الاقل ينبئ بان هناك احساس
بان الروايه الاسرائيليه لم تعد مقنعه في
الوسط الاعلامي والسياسي الفرنسي وجزء من
هذا الامر هو مرتبط ايضا بهذه التظاهرات
وضغط الشارع وبالتالي يمكن ان نقول ان
اسرائيل تفقد كما عنونت صحيفه فرنسيه اكثر
فاكثر حلفائها شكرا ا